yeah hello went to welcome to this video
play Prince panic really Hendrix what is
he playing is the Sicilian player okay I
did not really have this on the way down
so let's see what we get here I'm going
for them Roxy point against account
variation bishop yeah that's also move
Bishop before as the other big choice
yeah this is the kind of thing I think
white is better than their source
positions here but it's tricky to play
and one thing that shouldn't be
underestimated is that in blitz chess
Blacks game is very easy he has all
those standard moves and he can play all
those moves very quickly and it's it's
it's not so easy for white to get to
time is play correctly night b3 this is
the general setup I guess would be one
this right 1g5 I want to have the c5
idea and not sure this is working though
d 5 ed ed c5 is the idea everything gets
taken at the end bishop a six and the
screen add ruckus in one file i know
that's a deep line but this is the
reasoning behind white set up ok still
place it ok then this is my they are the
only way to justify what I did ok so I
wonder if there's something only three
actually some tactic I can also just
take on d5 but then the SB should be six
does this kind of situation quite often
gives black mm gives black enough c5
I can actually take with this so at the
end Bishop a 6 it could work there is
screen a seven though okay so um if I
take instead how bad is that see if it's
very complicated takes takes Knight
takes Knight takes bishop takes look
take like the end Bishop 87 Queen a
seven Bishop d7 and it's a chick that
isn't all that great okay so I'm taking
this one not so happy here I wanted to
play c5 but maybe it didn't work so now
this is a text and not so easy to defend
as after g3 will probably just sacrifice
at age three weekends the dark squares
considerably but I'm not quite sure
about anything else not not happy with
this you can check and go night age five
immediately huh Jesus I already have to
look at this slide this is not a good
version of the head shop for black but
you have to know it with white and I
don't mean in the situation in a
situation like this you should know how
to refute this because it's probably
refutable unless I already made some
mistake which is possible really
normally black does not get this in so
okay so this is looking dangerous
but how good is it he's got all kinds of
stuff coming here rookie 3 and the whole
dark squares are mess but it's this how
bad is that I know it looks terribly
weakening but may I just need some space
here I need some space ship h2 kingi to
know I have to go to jail
Wow looks terrible but at least that
sets him some some concrete is I'm some
concrete problems he was threatening
Bishop H 293 any way that that looked
terrible Jeremy what is gesture from
luck okay so this thing I wonder yeah
I'm going to G to hear that was my idea
but he might have Knight takes Knight
takes to coverage III was my point he
might have roots III hear something
something like that to get to g3 with
the Queen that probably works or maybe
something else I don't know wacky stuff
just the night move somewhere I can I
def five I don't have a bishop f2
there's probably some kind of win for
black but I don't see it at the moment
yes this is something that could work
for sure so I have to check with the
rook I guess so let's see us is winning
for him do I have to take cross the wall
probably yes so the check is coming but
check but you will take the five a
sister thing
drew so I go here am I really doing this
position so f 3 is hanging okay night
here this Bishop is trapped on h2
no he's running out of gas here unless
I'm overlooking stuff he's got nothing
in he's got nothing Queen age three I
even have Queen G to prevent even the
check on f3 and his fault he sported
certainly I mean that was that was very
good very good for him probably a win
somewhere check probably I could have
taken the bishop but this will win at
least timewise it well it's actually
position wise isn't that clear i
actually i miscounted yeah i thought i
was up more material but i will probably
win do it with the time 94 years hanging
time warning ok so we're sooo supposed
to go think I go back and now bring the
bring the night out I get to trade this
and it should be very helpful check
check now now the position is also
winning not just the clock black
forfeits on time hmm I certainly miss
plate that somehow but he he bungled it
up the setup is usually quite good the
general setup that white hands here but
don't ask me about the specifics so he
played queen bee eight this is the
normal way of doing it but maybe d5 love
it just works it probably does this was
my attention but you know hear hear hear
hear hear hear hear hear he's got Queen
a7 and that works that was the line that
I saw and here I'm in some problems not
sure if I'm losing here necessarily but
it looks strange I saw this this and I
didn't see anything forward is equal
material I'm haven't won anything so
yeah so that didn't work so i decided to
take but yeah i'm in trouble definitely
I mean age three already sucks Oh
computer wants to take on c3 commanded
that that cannot be bad night age five
yeah g4s the kind of move that
ok show me and probably you can show me
check this this Queen g3 okay now push
up f1 now that looks awful I mean there
should be some way to punish me check
and this is probably also not bad even
though I mean hear the engine is kind of
okay with the police first first
calculation check here you Pelias
bungled it up and I can't I can take
this but I wasn't completely so to check
out the situation can't my king that
open but the inside secrets are okay but
okay I have to say that the time chance
was a factor because I thought if I'm
not getting mated quickly I'm going to
win on time so that was a practical
decision yeah I think I probably there's
something with the move on here maybe I
have to from here do more prophylactic
moves things like King here Bishop g1
those kind of things are kind of
commonplace maybe to just be more
prophylactic against e5 and only later
think about those ideas on the queenside
the way I played it was certainly wrong
water ok guys thanks for watching